[Music]
h3
after dark christmas special now
that always turns it up a little bit too
high for me
and he's finished shocking
dan you're very excited today it's the
uh this is the finale this is the big
show
this is our last big time baby this is
our last show of the year and i'm
feeling very melancholy about it even
though it's just a two-week break
we're taking a two-week break but i feel
sad that we're going to be gone from you
guys for two weeks because
i have to say that over this year with
kovit and everything happening i feel
that we've
we've formed a stronger bond than ever i
agree
with the and the frequencies of the
shows and stuff and
you know as a youtuber i think every
youtuber has this fear
of like i'm going to leave for two weeks
and then you're going to leave me
and i don't want you guys to leave
youtube algorithm we'll
mess my whole channel up love would you
leave me if
i leave left for two weeks of course not
never
thanks bro i'll still be here thank you
man love is by the way
um he works with us on highlights he's
going to be having a simp
off with a b today imp
you know we have such an amazing show
planned today
it is so ridiculous the amount of good
[ __ ] we have planned today
um i'm just so excited
um should i explain my costume sure go
ahead
um party time mrs uh claws
you gotta kind of stand up secretly
i was like damn mrs claus
got a thing going on
much to show but just mrs claus is
looking
it's a smoke show this year you guys
what does it mean that the
the grinch is with mrs claus
i think it means mr claus is a cup this
year that's right
yeah this is like a biggie being like
that's why i [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ]
or tupac saying that's a biggie you know
go shoddy go shoddy
so anyway oh today is sponsored by who's
our sponsor
roman anyway
you know a little background on the
grinch outfit which is obviously we went
all out we probably we spent like gatsby
money on this
you know what i mean and the purpose was
because
trisha was like i'm gonna come as the
grinch
on our christmas episode and
i kind of have a reputation for outdoing
her on the
costumes yeah so i was like oh we this
is gonna be like the worst one ever i'm
gonna get like movie quality
prosthetic but this is our last show so
i'm not gonna be able to do that but you
know i'm happy to do it today
you know this is definitely what it
feels like to be jewish on christmas by
the way
i've always thought the grinch was a jew
like it's so obvious
that it's like an anti-semitic tale
all jews yes keemstar agrees not
surprised
but it's like there's this green slimy
freak who's like running around trying
to ruin christmas for everybody
it's like oh yeah he's jewish the grinch
is jewish that's the story
you know it's such an anti-semitic story
actually dr
seuss was a well-known anti-semite i'm
just kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding no
he wasn't
yeah don't do that i'm kidding all jews
keepstar however
but anyway you know i i thank you all so
much for being here
and i want to actually i wanted to give
a heart felt kind of little thank you at
this moment
because the show's been through a lot of
ups and downs
and i feel like we really had a down
moment in the beginning of this year
maybe the end of last year i don't know
yeah but i think a lot of people were
kind of giving up on the show
including almost ourselves including
ourselves because
for whatever reason you know i
no point in listing them off here but
you know
all these guys we've we've been working
super hard
and i've made it a point to make the
show
as special and as fun
and exciting and and to rejuvenate it
and i thank you all for giving us a
chance and some of you giving us a
second chance
and um
i you know i really love doing it now
where before it was like i have to be
honest before it was like every episode
was like
that episode sucked and i hate it and i
hate doing this now i look forward to it
today
i look forward to doing this show today
and um
i just want to thank you guys you know
for sticking with us
and allowing us to improve and to get
our bearing
and to actually make a show that we're
proud of and just for giving us that
chance
i also want to say how much of it
has to do with our uh
amazing krill who
we just have this really i think we have
a really good
uh chemistry or normal chemistry but
like synergy we're all
really learning to work together we're
gonna say
but you know i mean dan does so much for
us it's hot it goes without saying
dan makes it all happen dan's the
skeleton of the show after who's that
i mean he really does everything
technically speaking
you've got ian who is the selfless
genius
two on the narcissism scale lowest score
of all time still think you cheated but
whatever
and you know ian you are such a funny
guy
i mean not i mean part of the journey
but i really do love you i think that
god brought us together
and i don't mean that lately because you
reached out this whole story
of us coming together and i feel like
you
you've blossomed into this really
incredible comedy
writer i would say even and i and i i'm
sure you'll continue to evolve
in that direction and i think you add a
lot to the show so thank you very much
that's very kind and the love goes both
ways and saying god brought us together
i'll
i'll be sure to let them know that you
said that because
because you have their ex contact a
saintly figure so
let god know i'll let him know thank you
zach by the way i mean sweet young zach
who came to us who came to us
a college student and now a college
dropout
amen to that baby but in that time i
will say
zach you have become the dream you are
the sound by god you are the music then
sound god you have
evolved so much over this year and the
drops are just
they dropped from heaven i remember when
we kind of
got upset the first time zach did the
ian and i got a p sound but
we were like yeah it sounded like ian
really said it yeah
you're right i was like it's confusing
but now you're cracking us up trust the
timing of your yeah that's very sweet i
trust you
and you you're always on it i appreciate
that and that's very sweet of you guys
and i've
it's been nothing but a dream working
for the crew and you guys and
i'm so grateful and fortunate thank you
zach love you
nab the newest edition
what can i say about ab that he hasn't
already said about himself
pretty high on the narcissism scale no
i'm kidding
a b actually i have to say i think ab
was the missing puzzle piece and i do
mean this because
he has taken so much work off me and has
made this process so enjoyable and so
seamless for me
that i we are able to come out here and
do three and four episodes a year
in a way that doesn't make me or
strike that go back three or four
episodes a week
in a way that is sustainable and i can
do that i'm happy and enjoy
doing because av puts a lot together he
does the content chords he puts the all
the documents together
organizes it and he he really does a lot
of the leg work
that he's taken off of me and allowed
this this show to flourish
and i've trusted and come to respect av
and i'm very glad that he's come into uh
into the fold and uh i do think he's
completed the puzzle piece there
so thank you thank you so much that
really means the world
you are star [ __ ] though though
a star [ __ ] star [ __ ] oh star [ __ ]
yeah ab that kind of brings me to the
next point
i was thinking about michael jackson
last night
and i know that you're def oh and by the
way thank you to all of our subscribers
and
and that that makes such a big
difference for the show you know over
this last
year we've lost a ton of sponsors
because apparently we're edgy or
something i don't know
i don't think so i mean we rocked the
boat a little bit but like i don't think
we're like bad people
yeah although who thinks they're a bad
person maybe you're a bad person
in which case i guess don't sponsor me
but anyway you guys be the judge of that
because your spot your
support money has made a huge difference
in our business and be able to do
this show um
the way we've been doing it and to have
and to continue to grow and build
nevermind thank you thank you thank you
thank you with peace and love
but now uh so peace and love peace and
love
amy you defend michael jackson right
sure don't say sure own it you
you defend michael jackson
i will say the documentary i don't the
documentary is not
do you think michael jackson is guilty
or innocent
i think he's innocent but i don't mean
any disrespect to anyone who's gone
through
you don't need to i know
you think he's innocent okay so i was
thinking like how can i
how can i prove to a b that michael
jackson is guilty
i was in the shower last night i was
thinking like you know because
everything's like
it's this and he said that and he said
that i said like how
what is the silver bullet argument that
puts this whole michael jackson debate
to rest and i think i've got it
a b if you find me one picture
of michael jackson hanging out with a
fat
not beautiful boy he only hangs out
with handsome little boys you never
hang out with fat kids or [ __ ] up
teeth kids with [ __ ] up teeth
they're always like beautiful little
child models
so you tell me why does michael jackson
only hang out with beautiful but you
find me a picture of him with one fat
little boy
and i'll say he's not guilty he's hung
out with a bunch of kids that had
disabilities one of the kids he was
closest with no no no no no the ones
that he sleeps in
yeah spend the night with them
whatever i mean it was it was the same
arrangement as whatever
whatever however they did it listen to
what you're saying arrangements
we don't make these arrangements because
it was like an amusement park i mean
they brought
you know their family park where you
sleep in adults bed i mean what the [ __ ]
how did we get to and michael jackson
well i was like right
now no but i was thinking like find me a
picture
of like because he used to have like his
little homies who were like his little
best friends he'd run around
here no this is a good vibe is it i
think so
but i'm just saying find me one of his
little homies that was a fat or ugly kid
sorry but of course i don't agree with
an adult being
sharing a bed with a kid of course i i
don't think anyone logically would agree
with that
uh-huh well shouldn't he be guilty in
just that sense alone yes
but we're not going to read we're not
we're not re-uh
litigating this i just had one point to
make
because i keep seeing people saying
ethan and amy need to do a content court
on michael jackson
they're saying it right now yeah content
caught up but that
i'm just being fbi ten-year
investigation
nothing whatever that's suspicious right
no it's fbi oj was innocent
yeah o.j got acquitted okay come on
let's move on i think my point is
is bulletproof it's it's it's it's gold
you find me that picture a.b with him
with the ugly kid and i'll say
innocent but you tell me they're all
beautiful
little supermodel boys
all right listen guys
i got a lot of problems today
yeah but i feel like going to war right
now we'll do the retrospective
thing yes all right enough good vibes
yes the good vibes are
i'm here for war foot soldiers we
assemble here today on christmas
to go to war against the wicked dave
portnoy you got it what's up all good
yeah i'm good
the makeup artist is peeking around the
floor
yeah we're good thank you i feel like
having the um
the christian bale freak out remember
when he's on the set of batman
with the sound yeah
what the [ __ ] what are you doing
yeah uh dave
portnoy you guys know this [ __ ] i gotta
take these off because i actually gotta
type and click [ __ ] now
so sorry i'm not actually i'm not
actually the grinch
not actually the grinch oh
amy sent me a picture presumably of
michael jackson no don't don't make me
look at this
did he travel around i'm not doing this
right now maybe yeah
i said that was sad i said fat boy
jesus av why do you got to bring down
the show like that he sent me up
here let me just show it so you guys
know what i'm talking about it's just
i mean it's like it's what you're saying
they're all beautiful like this no but
this is
okay this is what a b sent me and how
they're here
yeah i mean what the [ __ ] why are you
gonna bring the show down like that doug
you're telling me sending you a picture
michael jackson and a fat boy i mean
it's kind of hard to
[Music]
come it's beyond my expertise
can you believe this guy no
all right let's talk about dave
merry christmas merry christmas
[ __ ] dave courtney i'm ready for
okay so dave porton you guys know he's
the
guy from bar stool sports or whatever
does the pizza review and everything
poor noy all right port
noy let me pull up a picture david
portly is how it's pronounced
wait what we all get confused because
we don't like him until we mess up his
name now
admittedly important night for tonight
admittedly okay trisha told me that she
was gonna go on his podcast
he has this podcast bff i guess he's a
bunch of because
and he has a podcast with the 18 year
old tick-tocker
uh-huh who's one of these guys who just
dances with the shirt off
and does like this
he just says yeah and he has a podcast
with his 18 year old he talks gossip and
[ __ ] and i was like he's
weird how old is he he's like [ __ ] i
don't know 40 in his 40s
43 43 40 30 there you go i mean look at
him
his face looked like he listen i know
who look who's talking all right but
talk to me baby but anyway i'm not gonna
make fun of the way he looks
she's fine but what i will say is that's
a little [ __ ] weird
and so trisha said i'm going on this
guy's podcast and i go [ __ ] dave fortney
creepy [ __ ] weird oh i don't give a
[ __ ] and i was and i was obviously
playing it up trying to cause beef with
them because yeah
delicious be transparent i i sometimes
you want beef for the sake of beef's
sake
sometimes you want beef for the sake of
beef's sake with
steak i just you know that's funny when
you did that
it goes in yeah
i don't know if you can zoom in on that
that's so funny
yeah it smells really bad inside of it
oh wait
do it again
[Laughter]
so anyway trisha came back did his
podcast
and she's like he was super rude and
mean to me
and i'm like you know trish is
my friend and i watched these clips and
i was kind of disgusted by the way they
talk to her
and so he's well let me start off
because he saw me just kind of goofing
on him
and he he his response to me saying he's
creepy for having a podcast
uh is is to make fun of my tourette's
which is
pretty epic here i'll let you watch have
a podcast that you i guess you canceled
like
recently right um yeah we're
me we're we're supposed to have it go
today we're meeting today to see
if it's going to continue i don't really
know it's kind of up to them like
i want to continue but i don't know up
to who
um it's like ethan and ela because it's
on their h3 channel so
uh and i'm the one that like cursed his
life this guy literally is like the
like i take it from me though a horrible
podcast host
this guy sucks like he he doesn't do any
research he doesn't know anything about
her
why is this computer so [ __ ]
look i'm talking about how bad of a
hosting is and i can't [ __ ] even play
video
come on
they don't really know what to do yet
got it i so let's
start with this because when we invited
you on and and
do you have any idea who i am josh is
brianna
did like are you aware of us at all yeah
i know you from the caller daddy scandal
like
like impulsive talked about you guys a
lot so that's how i know you okay
got it so we asked you to be on the show
and then we have this clip here of this
is the guy you do the podcast with
um and let's start with that because he
was kind of trashing me
oh i was asked to be on marshall sports
don't do it
no he has one with like 68. he has one
that's pretty [ __ ] weird i have to
say
with two like 16 year old tick talkers
that he's on
or something wait what he hosts it with
two 16 year old tic talkers and i find
it really [ __ ] weird
he talks about tick tock drama with a
little i'm not gonna be invited on
i'm just saying i find it hard i don't
know what's the deal with that guy he
is he is he good or is he a weirdo
oh it's called oh maybe this is it it's
called bff yeah that's the one with the
six-year-old tick tuckers it's super
i mean in my opinion it's really weird
and crazy but it says dave pointer and
josh yeah he's on it
every time i see a clip of it i go oh
that's [ __ ] weird that he's done
look at this this you're gonna sit with
a bunch of six-year-olds
okay let's not say sixteen if they're i
eighteen why
why is he making a pot here's the other
girl fair point yeah but
don't you find it a little odd that this
grown up okay how long have they been 18
find out dan i bet they just turned and
he signed him he's like
he's like 18th birthday let's go bffs
now i'm best friends forever with the 18
year old boy
uh his birthday is january of uh
january so he's been 18 all this year i
guess
huh i'm sorry that doesn't help
i don't know how long their podcast has
been going but let's just
imagine for the sake of my beef that he
signed his ass
on day one of 18. like this girl
who's nessa
[Laughter]
on this guy's podcast when i got
flicking sounds
dan is a great guy no no donald you got
that wrong this time buddy
how would i write some super chats okay
well it's
ready sorry to get to the bottom of this
you're gonna go on the show we gotta
[ __ ] vet him
why is a 43 year old have a podcast with
two 18 year olds that's
weird dave courtney he's a little
[ __ ] weird and i almost saw people
dave with bor with bart's still sports
don't give a [ __ ] just because of my ed
version i think do you think it's weird
but in general
go on but you have to plug this show
more than talk about anything else
okay okay dude okay okay
i feel like your take that was kind of
like being
silly yeah i was just i was like i
didn't actually expect him to take the
bait yeah because i was like i'm just
fine
i'm just having fun i actually i don't
even know anything about him or the 18
year old
but like so he responded by taking a
really low blow out
which kind of got me excited because
then i was like oh well now we do have
beef you know what i mean
so here's here's a wicked the wicked
dave port needs response to me
wicked dave we invite you on now i i
don't know really who this guy is
and i saw that i saw the clip i'm gonna
start by saying this
well he has a lot to say the 18 year old
very insightful
you guys will see he's really insightful
i don't know who this ethan
is nah i wish my job was that easy
nah nah you got abs bro
once upon a time did you really yeah
when i was younger
if you show off your abs maybe i'll uh
take some of your workload off
you know what i mean because this kid
the 18 year old is apparently really
popular on tick tock
how many followers does he he's got like
billions right
uh not i don't know i mean he's got
millions and millions
he has uh 23 million followers holy
mother of moses can you send me a link i
want us to look at his abs
maybe we could have him as a co-host
well that's not saying if av
had a tick tock with that many followers
that do a lot for the show
your tick tock game slacking maybe
definitely shocking
[ __ ] slacking you got me that link so
here's let me just do some research on
this kid who's apparently qualified to
post it
uh podcast
[Laughter]
oh he is jack bro
[Music]
oh i see very talented dude
i could do that bro
[Laughter]
so nah
anyway that's what he does this is the
majority of his tick tocks just just to
give you context
and you know what he's 18 so i don't
really i can't trash on 18 year olds you
know i mean it's like whatever
but it's really dave wicked dave
and when we get ourselves you can't have
whatever i twitch
that guy has and call another person
weird
like that guy right that right
universally
strange weird without knowing a thing
it's like oh
that guy is somebody that will like
throw a kid in a van
type vibes without dave you're the one
hosting a show with the 18 year old who
just
clicked over from 17. if you want to
talk about the likelihood of someone
being thrown in a van
your ass is way more approximate to that
okay
i'm sitting here married bro you're like
the weird [ __ ] like bachelor
like i have get the feeling that he's
like the bachelor life kind of guy is he
married
you know what i mean i mean the spray
tan like this this guy is like
one night out drinking away from being
me too by like a thousand girls you know
what i mean like day four
dave me too portly trust me this guy's
[ __ ]
he uh i just looked up he was he was
married it looks like
he's separated oh maybe divorce i'm
sorry to hear that dave i know divorce
is tough
yeah you mentioned having some sex tapes
leaked
oh dude this is he's he's i'm not
talking about throwing in a van
you know this guy bro you know this guy
travels with like uh
dave come on gp coming at you yeah
it's total gp vibes
i mean but like
let me think about it right here reminds
me
with the age thing too dave he's really
trying to throw in like the 16 thing
like he really
low balls bro just show your abs i mean
really like
just why are you even wearing a shirt if
you're going to be on this podcast
he's the opposite of bryce and how old
are you josh
i'm 18. so he didn't get him yeah
yeah he's 18. dave's like well i mean it
was
it was corrected by trisha you know what
they you know what the average
uh age of the girls that dave sleeps
with
i think it's uh 17.5 because in some
states the legal agent can send 16.
got him so he's like yeah it's like 17
on average but it's always legal
you're right
okay but they're still like [ __ ] like
two decades younger than you dude that's
kind of my point
but like you know he let me go back
because he actually made fun of my
tourette's which is kind of epic i mean
like i'm pretty [ __ ] i don't know by
the way i'm goofing on you for
giving to me it seems like you're
clearly goofing
yeah it took it it took it so personal
and
he chose divorced arguments he said i'm
loving grenades but that's what i'm
saying he doesn't do his research he
doesn't come prepared because he didn't
know that i was going to come full
grinch and come on the foot army
because this guy thinks he's just
[ __ ] around with
you know like i'm the beef chef
right i'm the gordon ramsay of [ __ ]
beef
right you know what i mean perfect
medium rare [ __ ]
and you're gonna come with the
terrestrial meat i'ma [ __ ] meet you
guys
you do also cook a perfect steak oh
wow thank you mrs i'm gonna take care of
you tonight
i'm gonna cook your steak medium rare
tonight girl gross
i know you're waiting around some meat
that's right impressed
whenever you made it there that was
impressive yeah
thank you baby let's listen to this one
more time
who this guy is and i saw that i saw the
clip
i'm going to start by saying this and
when we get ourselves
you can't have whatever i twitch that
guy has
and call another person weird yes i can
and i did
and by the way because i have tourette's
i'm not allowed to have an opinion
i'm not allowed to criticize anyone
listen if you've got an
eye twitch you're not allowed to call
anybody weird
you sure about that dave how could he
get
this so wrong to go after an eye twist
but that's like
that that's like the argument the 18
year old would make right and i
understand not why he has a podcast with
a 18 year old because mentally that's
where he is
i mean who would claim to be bffs with
the 18 year old
as a 43 year old man
who's nah who by the way average
dating uh girl he dates
average age 18.1 no maybe
17.5
dave portney is one
dave me too courtney he's seriously one
block out away from getting [ __ ]
arrested for
molestation
you know i'm but you know it's true i
mean come on
that guy right that guy's universally
strange
weird without knowing a thing it's like
oh that guy
is somebody that will like throw a kid
in a van type vibe cause i have an
eye twitch bro
come on dave i don't know
i love it though i was so giddy when i
saw this i was like let's go
dave without knowing anything like how
are you gonna bring that up look who's
talking
it's good i mean he does have spray tan
on right oh does he
i don't know that's what it looks like
to me oh date no i don't think no
you think it's freytan i anyone else got
an opinion
i need teresa i love it i don't think he
is free i'm just noticing the 43 year
old with the pube beard
oh damn i'm sorry that's a man with a we
shouldn't make fun of his physical
appearance
see that's the low blood i just make fun
of the fact that he hangs out with kids
and then
and his spray tan and his shitty beard
come on
i want to make fun of someone's beer go
ahead at zach
he thinks he's like like jordan belfort
in a way like wolf of wall street
because there was a video he posted he's
like this is a three thousand dollar
gucci
suit you know this is it it's just so
much like
look what i have yeah yeah
anyway so but anyway you know what that
made me laugh that he was like going
so apparently because i have tourette's
i'm not allowed to call anyone weird
because i'm the ultimate weirdo
universally
i'm universally the biggest weirdo oh
thanks by the way dave
you know how long it takes me to come
here and sit in front of a camera and
[ __ ]
for 10 hours every week and twitch out
like a freak
you think i don't know that do you think
you know that i'm a freak and i come
here
my eyes are switching my [ __ ] wrists
are going bad [ __ ] crazy
have the courage to sit here in front of
all these people and be judged by
[ __ ] like you
by [ __ ] frat [ __ ] like you yeah
i'm not in college anymore they don't
have to take your [ __ ] [ __ ] you frat
[ __ ] you [ __ ] get how many girls do
you give chlamydia [ __ ]
like seriously dave this isn't a [ __ ]
frat house dude it's time to grow up
stop hanging out with 18 girls and start
[ __ ] doing adult [ __ ]
i do want to tell you that ethan's
eyebrows
he even got their own channel at one
point my eyebrows are famous [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] frat [ __ ]
what's your favorite beard natty light
[Applause]
you probably shot the natty light every
night [ __ ]
he's definitely a frat boy though who
has given how many times have you passed
on gonorrhea
just answer the question dave
anyway appreciate you
[Music]
so
so that that was about me but like so
sister
snatch you know he had reason to go
after me because i kind of just went
after him for no reason
yeah but like the shade he threw at
trisha actually made me upset
like that [ __ ] was just i did america's
i was just giggling because
you know i went for him first and he
took debate and i thought it was fun
but like trisha didn't do anything you
know what i mean they invite her on
their show and they're so [ __ ]
rude to her it really upset me and
howard stern and then like
shane and me so that was like the big
thing what do you mean you did america
yeah yeah i'm sorry yeah we didn't do
any we don't know anything about you we
didn't do any research
last year yo america's got talent you're
on the show as a
as a what i was like a contestant do you
know anything about the show
it's so easy it's a clip on youtube yeah
you were on the show as a what
i don't think there's more than one
option you know what i mean
she was she was a performer that's
literally the only option
zach is laughing what happened zack he
called him [ __ ]
you like that i love zach [ __ ] face
that's all it took
it's awesome i hope everyone in the
audience is having a good time with zach
all right now you're just blowing smoke
up my ass you can always cut to me and
if you need it
yeah and i said [ __ ] face any uh
laughter over there
no ho ho no
no like 20. i was like
really good actually what were you were
you like we have was it like a second
big thing
we got it
i mean that's so [ __ ] yeah i'm
triggered
it just makes i mean it really is a
disgusting comment
how many dicks you was were you sucking
how many dicks you could suck
thing what's a blue job
i found his movements more offensive he
went like this
why because it wasn't accurate no she
was like lego's two
dicks at once he was doing a tick tock
dance out of it
poor vet corvette he's practicing for
later
this is what happens though when you
make a 18 year old your co-host
you know what i mean right and you it's
like no dude you know
[ __ ] you bro and by the way who are you
to judge
trisha for anything she's done in her
past when you are literally basically
i mean what he's doing is really not
that far off i mean he's kind of like a
pornographer for little girls on tick
tock
the kid the kid well yeah i thought we
said we weren't going to go after the
kid
okay we did say that
i'm the grinch though so give me a pass
here today
this is a very uh dramatic after dark we
usually avoid these kinds of dramatic
topics because it's alive i need to keep
it and i like to walk things back when i
go too far
but i can't there's no walking it off
today ladies and gentlemen
to an end that's all i get out there and
we're doing it live
yeah watch it right here sort of is like
what you got mad about
like charlie and dixie was being like
i'm gonna have a hundred million
right but but that to me is like who
cares that that i would never cancel
somebody
that almost sounds like somebody who's
just sucking dick on street corners for
five bucks doesn't like somebody who got
fame like overnight
yeah [ __ ] you dude i mean seriously eat
[ __ ] bro what
how did she respond to that i don't
think she knows how to respond i mean
it's like it's hard sometimes people are
so shockingly rude
you're not prepared yeah you kind of
like try to brush it off and also when
you're a guest on someone's show you
don't expect to be treated so
disrespectfully so it's like
she mentioned that she when she was
younger she did that and
earlier in the show but still obviously
that he knows that that's surreal right
but no he he's clearly
yeah so condescending
wow rude gross
you know what's bad too is that you know
it's a lot of young people watching
because of his co-host and they think
like
pepper their world worldview you know
unlike me i
educate and mature my viewers all right
these guys are just not good
wicked man that dave portney he's a
wicked
he's wicked and take it from me i'm the
[ __ ] grinch
that's actually not true i think there's
a lot of humility in people i don't like
people that off the bat think that
they're already so famous
definitely cancel there's not a bigger
is there more um maybe
being mean nutritious it's just yeah
yeah i mean it's not significant it's
just i watch
it i like it you have to
die on the internet what'd a pesticide
pesticide why do you hate himself wait
she called him a she called him a
pesticide
yeah she meant to say parasite oh i was
like
i gotta i got actually gotta stop you
there
this pesticide is good i think in your
name oh my god
he is absolutely disgusting can we get
you on the record or just saying hitler
was a bad guy
hitler was not a bad guy i'm learning
more about she goofed up
we've all established with trisha we've
all established but
and she corrects herself we've all
established with trisha that hitler is a
bad guy we've gone through a lot of
education
she correct she corrects herself every
day
no you just said he wasn't a bad guy
right you said he was not a bad guy i
think we got
i think we all got to unite that hitler
was a bad guy
james charles said on his ticket trisha
says hitler wasn't that bad i was like
that's put in my mouth right we watch
okay
we want you to say he's terrible right
now i don't like hitler right
he's not in support of him there we go
god holy [ __ ]
i don't know james i don't i've never
met him um but just how he acts towards
me or even h3 the guy that i host with
you know he stole his sweater design and
he's like too bad i'm still selling him
like he openly admitted in the dms that
he stole the design and he was being a
little like
[ __ ] about it i will say this is gross
yeah that is something
always i feel like sister clarified and
somebody's like you so you know shane
personally you don't know james charles
at all
like so you're going off you go back
well you said you're not sure if you're
doing this podcast anymore
with this dude are you gonna do this
dude you know who i am now [ __ ]
oh by the way speaking of this dude he's
gonna act like he doesn't know who i am
let's go let's just do an exercise can
we dave portney wiki feed
okay let's see what he's got on wiki
fees
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god wait he's already at one star
wait people already wrote for him i
think
people on the subreddit may have took
action already
soldiers foot soldiers we love our foot
soldiers man these guys don't know the
definition of war
to smell feet so
i mean listen this guy's going to call
some me
weird when he has a one star on wiki
feet
do you know what i mean
what is this wait why am i looking at
this
bro what the [ __ ] what
i'm tripping out about that photo holy
[ __ ]
bro you really gonna sit here and call
me weird when you have one star
it's pathetic it's pathetic frank
dave courtney what a weirdo one star
freak okay
you know what i mean and then hold on
let me just go over to me actually you
know what we should do let's go to
celebrities
let's sort by sight rating
you know just to see who's the oh my god
is that me
why is a bee number two man
i can't believe av is snuck in the
number two on the website
i'm part of the family i'm part of the
family [ __ ] wait look at this guy ben
shot he's literally like a foot fetish
like what is these photos bro
this guy is literally just doing
footborne like what the [ __ ] are these
photos ben
oh my god what what
this guy hates us to be honest this guy
should be number one
i feel bad because dedication yeah this
guy should be number one
i want to smell feet oh my goodness
so do you think this guy has a foot
fetish or he just discovered i don't
have food fetish
yeah oh my god this is getting too much
for me
well unfortunately for ben you can't
hold a candle to me
but you are close to a b so i wish you
luck in that battle
but as far as my score is concerned i
mean eight points
yeah six i mean come on and
i read the super chat yes please yes oh
this one from vacation is already up
okay
high-rise suicides for 20 says hey ethan
just a heads up dave fourtney is
notorious for
never losing a beef in his life he has
literally ruined multiple people's
careers
after they beefed with him fan of both
you so i'm conflicted but team h3 all
day
oh so what give me some
he's famous for never losing a beef i
mean he already lost
this beef you know what i mean
like dude came out making fun of my
tourette's
beef is cooked bro you're gonna send an
18 year old army after you
he does seem like the kind of guy that
would try to ruin my career though but
like i mean
there's no one beef that he lost he lost
the beef with the national labor
relations board oh
yes we did it you want to tell us
yeah this guy's east he tweeted a bunch
of [ __ ] about how he's gonna fire his
staff if they try to unionize which is
very illegal and
also very plain filed with the uh nlrb
and he had to retract it all and delete
all the tweets and uh
yeah he got owned so that's one beef on
the record he's lost
so that's why you hired all 18 year olds
they're like these guys don't know
anything about labor laws
this isn't my first rodeo right
he's basically what's that guy's name
from the uh that insurance
[ __ ] i'm selling he's tom selleck with
these [ __ ] kids
life insurance you know
he does seem like the kind of guy that
would try to like ruin my career
vengeance for me just goofing on him but
he doesn't know that i've already
tangled with the devil
himself and i've come out alive on the
other end
if keemstar can't ruin my [ __ ] life
dave fort and you sure can't even touch
me
there's no [ __ ] unturned in our
background no there's nothing bro
every stone's been unturned and i'm
still here standing before you
green as a [ __ ] garbage
dave's probably watching this like what
is going on why are these guys so angry
yeah i'm just having fun dave you [ __ ]
i'm just having fun i'm sorry
yeah i mean let's be honest like
keemstar is basically
it's satan yeah yeah if you can survive
i basically survived the full-on blast
from the death star
no someone sent that in our discord
server wait am i supposed to open the
fro
okay this was sent on the first one
first cam sent that
so yeah of course now the fact
is that my real body no that's not my
body who's that
body you don't know your body is it not
oh i don't
know i thought it was just from the baba
boom it is my body well
it's like distorted though yeah
but oh it's my baba booey body yeah i
mean bro you really hanging out topless
just
a couple of homies weird bro
that is fun wait so what is this
probably photo they're not
no they are what's the origin photo here
they are
they are here's the united one here
what's the origin i mean speaks for
itself you know
it says all you need to know about the
guy really
that's a real photo that's weird hey
dave have you ever been blocked
dude he's probably david's probably so
confused like why is
this guy's problem and to be honest
yeah i don't know anything about him he
might be fine
i'm just i i'm honestly i'm just having
fun yeah
you know um okay
but if anyone has anything to add i'd
love to hear it
uh we have an ad that we need to do a
perfect little pun there
yeah pretty good not bad thank you
oh but we have more tricia clips to
watch don't we or no
let's finish this clip let's finish this
that's pretty much all the excitement
because
yeah basically it was just trisha saying
that hitler didn't do anything wrong or
something that didn't help our case
really
thank you zach so in short dave i'm just
having fun
so don't try to ruin my career or
whatever we're both jews apparently so
that's good
you just seem like kind of like the
douchey jew like there's like douchey
jews you know what i mean
and you're the weird jew i'm a weirdo
which yeah
jews he's like a weinstein jew you know
what i mean
so yeah i began to jerk off into his
planner
yeah for sure someone said
dave literally said he writes the names
of his enemies on champagne bottles
and pops it when he destroys them oh my
god
yeah he's normal watched a little too
much peaky blinders
i know dude that's
not healthy bro you should stop doing
that
we have the legendaries miller in the
chat he donated five dollars said
portnoy's dead has a radio show where
they have a money pool going for what
celebrities will die next
yeah yeah howard stern does that too so
i can't hate it's a little dark though i
agree
[Music]
wait what's his dad do um
do you think he's at home watching this
right now feel me because i'm sure
people told him they're live and
trashing you so he's probably turned it
on he's probably writing my name on a
champagne bottle right now
ethan ethan klein
what enemies does he have i don't have
any enemies that i would work you know
what i mean
except him obviously no
i guess that's it i'm just having fun
though
i really am i don't mean any hate to him
obviously and
you know he'll help a lot of like i mean
bill how long was it before bill cosby
even got caught or harvey weinstein so
he's got plenty of time left to have fun
you know what i mean like he's got
plenty of time to have to enjoy his life
i'm more planners than jerk often do no
but i don't mean anything weird or
hateful by it
um let's do an ad
oh we have all kinds of roasts here this
is so stupid weird like me
this was like mostly me and dan last
night
let's see dave portly is the type of
dude to go to target without a mask
on he did go on like an
anti-mask rant on twitter it did yeah
well
more anti-government shutdown rant it
wasn't that bad
he made so much he made some points but
okay
i won't fault him for that dave portly's
the type of guy to call his niece a
smoke show
dave portly is the type of dude who
would [ __ ] with an std and not say
anything
dave portly the type of dude to put the
ghb
in the wrong drink and black out for 16
hours
oh everybody's coming didn't like that
one
rice what'd you think
okay delayed but he liked it
dave porton he's the type of guy to eat
nachos naked and burn his dick with
molten cheese
dave bart needs to tie a guy who buys
some teens white claw to hang out with
them and then get ditched
dave courtney that definitely happens by
the way you know he goes and buys that
kid white claws after every show
he probably pays him a white claws he's
like listen just don't tell the labor
board then i'm paying you on white claws
dave portland is the type of guy to day
trade and lose half a million dollars
that actually happened right
true story what's the story with that
one
he because he he's really into gambling
i guess and he got out of the gambling
game and instead decided he was going to
try
day trading and like immediately because
that's not gambling six hundred thousand
dollars
which he's very wealthy so i guess he
can yeah he's raising money he's really
rich
uh wow this i didn't
write this one so i'm just going to read
it is it dave partly the type of dude to
say feminism has cocked western men
then hire a hooker to squeeze lemon
juice in his paper cuts
that sounds like anything yeah i mean
that's pretty complex
idea you're trying to convey that's out
there dude yeah that's pretty wild bro
no but with peace and love dave like i
i don't know how to put this don't try
please don't come for me please don't
try to destroy my life we're just having
fun
with peace and love bro you've built an
empire you're very successful
i wish you a merry chris well you're not
you're jewish like me
and i wish you a happy new year and a
great uh lots of success
and everything so with peace and love my
dude
right like can we bury the beef now
it's no beef here okay what are we doing
we're doing uh
we're doing we're thanking our sponsor
is romance listen
robins it can be
awkward or embarrassing to talk about
erectile dysfunction
usually we brush it off or blame
ourselves but roman is here to get you
the advice you want
and to help you need help you need with
no shame
how often do you give excuses like i had
a long day at work
or i'm just not feeling it it isn't easy
to talk about erectile dysfunction but
romans makes it easy to discuss and
treat eddy
a healthy life includes lots of sex but
if you struggle with the erectile
dysfunction you may not feel
like your best self if you want to help
your erectile dysfunction roman
connection with a real doctor
u.s licensed health care professionals
who can prescribe the medicine you need
to keep your dick rock
rock hard
with roman you get a free online
evaluation
and ongoing care for e.d darling
oh from the comfort and privacy of your
home now let me see your dick
oh we can do something about that
a healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate roma will
ship you real medicine with a
free two-day shipping the whole process
is straightforward simple
and discreet getting started is simple
just go to roman.com
h3 and complete an online visit
you do not have to send pictures of your
dick
please just in case you were worried
about them
erectile dysfunction used to be tough to
talk about darling but now there's a
roman
complete an online visit today to
connect with a doctor and take care of
it
go to roman.com h3 to get 50
off your first month of boner pills
treatment and a free online visit
oh [ __ ] me back it up
just go to get roman.com
h3 one more time because i said it wrong
the first time
get roman.com slash h3 they do not like
when you say they're you are wrong
kind of defeats the whole purpose so
i'll say one more time for the god
get roman.com h3 to get
up to 50 off your first month of ed
treatment
a free online visit and free two-day
shipping that's
get roman.com h3 for up to fifty dollars
off your first month of ed treatment
roman.com h3 let's get those dicks nice
and hard boys
[Music]
thank you thank you for correcting me
dan that would have been annoying
you know that's what i'm here for
so god there's so much to get to today
you guys
there's so much let's talk let's okay
um oh you know the buck candle that we
sold
hang on i gotta post this tick tock this
is good content
here either talk to them what i just
have to post this real fast you want me
to talk about the candle here
i'm done already i'm done i'm done wow
he's so fast he's such a he's such a
good tick tock well
you can talk about the candle i just i
didn't know what we were gonna say about
it
so here's what we're gonna do yeah you
guys remember we made the candle that
smells like my [ __ ]
of course people started to get by the
way we raised almost eight thousand
dollars for prostate cancer
that's awesome i wish i would have
bought more because i wasn't really sure
but those things man they sold like like
uh like hot kicks
like hot farts yeah that's right
and um we got some reactions
i told people to record their reaction i
really wanted people to like light it
at a family dinner so today i got a
very interesting and just get people's
reaction as it fills the room
but here you get a few reactions give
you the idea same thing i would didn't
mail today
a candle that supposedly smells like a
bomb yup
of course i was really worried about
this
is going to be the real deal so here we
go i'm smelling it it's the real deal
brother
you know we don't [ __ ] around straight
but
it smells like you just yeah
you all thought i was joking huh god
wasn't at all
here's another one i don't know if i
let's see
first soldier as well i haven't seen
this one oh he's a foot soldier
yeah my boy let me just note that this
first time lighting it
nothing yet but it's lit
if we have it lit
oh my the stench has hit exchange has
hit
i don't know how i describe this but if
if you've ever been to an assisted
living center
oh god dude assisted living holy oh my
god that's dark
a whiff of a god this guy is funny it's
awful
but beautiful at the same time a smell
of assisted living bro that's what's up
i i do think we need to raise talk yeah
i think we need to restock because
it's such a great gag and it's for a
good cause you know
based on the size and weight i'm pretty
sure i know exactly what this is so
yes sir say what i just
maybe he covered it there was an address
i think i saw a sharpie okay good it was
it was sharpie yeah let's see what are
they gonna do
some random dude please just get it open
i have to assume there's a lot more
demand for this candle because it's sold
out like
an hour or two yeah we just really
didn't know
but i'm really proud of of the product
we've you know yeah
like gwyneth paltrow such a bullshitter
she just made like a nice
smelling candle i actually went out of
my way to
make a formulation this is not like my
[ __ ] oh god i don't know if i want to
open this
oh my god dude i'm so proud of us
oh my god there's no lid there's no lid
what the [ __ ] guys
dude i'm so proud about this candle
we've made
yeah i think we got to make more that's
great
i'm so happy with that the smell is not
just farts i'm telling you guys it's
very unique it's not just like
what you would expect it's it's got
layers it's complex
it's like it's like it's like an aged
bottle of wine
oh yeah so um
maybe we should just put in an order dan
you know yeah i can
talk to the to the candle makers i'm
starting to get a headache from this
grinch get up i'm not even going to
lie about it i don't know if it's like
my nose constriction or i have a cap on
my head that's like tight
but i'm here for it i soldier through
definitely going to soldier through i
can make them get my money's worth on
this
so
you guys seen i mean listen i have to
talk about shoe nice
shoe nice he's on standby by the way
shoe nice
has apparently been sober i told shu
that he can't come back on a show until
he's sober
right he says he's been sober he was
doing
like liquor slams i was like sure you
know you gotta
i don't want to enable you or your bad
behavior
but i don't know what to do because like
on yesterday's episode
this was the comments look at this have
you seen this
i'm going to get actual feedback and
the top like 300 comments are all shoe
oh my god no i don't know why
youtube allows this first of all
you know what i mean i have to assume
it's because he's an actual verified
account he like
gets exempted from the spam filter
maybe he's because he yeah that's true i
mean
so i don't see anybody else he's
definitely exploiting yeah if you you
would have like spammers and [ __ ]
and scammers doing it but he's
exploiting his status and this isn't the
first time he's done it by the way
he does this regularly and so i'm torn
like i don't want to ban
[ __ ] get bring show on the on the phone
i'm gonna ask him what the hell's going
on
are you there wait hold on he's joining
takes a second
and cause like
i see him i i don't wanna oh there it is
hello hello if you want
to be involved in the show you know how
to reach the guys you don't have to spam
or comment
reach the guys hey you know that guy
from barstool
sports yeah i've known that for 10 years
bro
really excuse me
you got any he became so cocky he's like
keemstar you know
really cool guy relatable we hung out on
facebook
i was his hero he shared my absolute
vodka
and 10 million people saw it you know
eight nine years ago
then he got you know the big money he
was bought out
i mean that dude is like literally the
biggest jerk i've ever met
he's like i want to be mark zuckerberg
he looks like chris martin from coldplay
jumped into the audience and nobody
caught him
[Laughter]
i'm so torn on you because you're such a
genuinely funny guy and i love talking
to you
but like how do you know it's been a
while it's been a while and i love
talking to you about are you have you
been sober
i've been training for the usc bro nice
you gonna fight jake paul
hey man they're scared of me dude i
think you would eat him alive bro
i come from a bloodline of fighters i i
don't even need a gym
other sweaty dude i trained myself i
believe in you
this would be me and the dude from
barstool sports what are the dave
ponytails i honestly think you could
take out like
the best shot right yeah
i honestly think you could take like a
price fighter like i
i honestly do i don't doubt that i
wonder if we could set up a h league
boxing match
bro but i think shoes were made for
sewing sweaters
so dave if you're watching this you're
talking [ __ ] about the h3h3 family
listen trista annoys me too but i'll
take you out bro a punch
merry christmas okay shoot wow now why
are you
why are you spamming our comments like i
have to
tell you and how long does it take you
to do that well
it's been hours man i thought i was
going to leave you guys alone
but then i went on to 1999 membership
bro
uh it does look like you're a twenty
dollar member you're
you're you're uh it's like insanity but
it's it's all
a method of operation wow well what i
wanted to tell you most about shoe is
if you keep doing that i'm gonna have to
ban you from
commenting so like because i go
hold on a second because
oh my god because she's in the chat
yeah because shoe i go there to see
comments and people want to
engage but when all the comments are
from you
it kind of i mean it's funny once but
it's a little bit much every time
i don't believe that for one second that
you go and look at all the comments
i go from 1 to 35 000 comment bro
i count to a thousand sometimes
well i'm just i'm just warning you with
peace and love
that i will have to ban you if you do
that again and if you want to get in
contact with the show
you know how to contact us you don't
have to spam our channel
i don't know i spent i you aren't the
only one i spam bro
okay but i'm just saying keep it off i'm
saying keep it out of our chat
spam whoever you want but keep it out of
our chat if you want to talk
what do you think about the shoes bro
it's like a koozie but i took a bite
mark
out of it so when you stick a can of
beer in it and you drink it
you're not hitting that that little lip
you always said oh
now you got a smooth pour well
that's a great invention take it on
shark tank man i'll invest
i think it's a great idea shoe with
peace and love
i'm just saying i will ban you with
peace can i sing you guys a
song yes yeah
please happy holidays to
you okay i said a happy holidays
whoever else is there happy holidays
thank you shoei thank you i just wanted
to check in i'm glad you're doing good
okay
have a great all day and next time am i
gonna be on this show when am i gonna be
in the studio
i want everybody in this chat to just
say hey man
let's go get shoe nice you're on the
show right now
you're on the show you're on the show
right now
i just want one shout out
i don't think i got through this i don't
know
how is he gonna be on the show and ask
when is he gonna be on the show
i think he wants to come in wants to
come to the studio he has to earn my
trust because
but we're not even in the studio
yeah he's still bitter but i mean look
it's too nice he's
hey if it doesn't work out with trish a
new new subject for frenemies
shoes
yeah i don't think i got through them i
think there's gonna be spamming
shoe i know you're listening and with
peace and love i will ban you if you do
it again
i will ban you and you oh man here we go
you're just gonna have to like i'd like
to check in with him he just said thank
y'all
shoot i'd like to check in with you just
message the guys you have
you have channels to do that yeah so
just for the record i
had three different phone numbers for
him because he
has these like burner phones oh my god
and none of them worked he said
well he has email i mean he has you guys
his email address you know why is he
using burner phones
he doesn't need to spam our chat every
episode that's all i'm saying
it won't be useful shoot to keep one
number where we can reach you
yeah he's like he's so slippery it's
like i don't know what
like he's just a joker yeah he's really
joker brained
yeah he's joker brain yeah do a bathroom
break i'd love to administer him a
personality test sure good
oh that's what someone in the chat said
oh
oh oh oh zach please send shu the
personality test
okay you got it but shu you have to be
honest like no
[ __ ] [ __ ] just be honest so
you'll ruin the bit
that's real that'll be really
interesting oh i'll show their speaking
uh so
what's your name super chats while
shredder's puking go ahead okay
he pukes regularly he's just uh
said 12 30 show i call that false
advertising
that's not fraud it's not fraud though
though it's not fraud
i would call that uh false advertising
that's said holy crap ethan looks
amazing so well done
thank you dude it costs like [ __ ]
thousands of dollars
andrew for 10 shout out from alaska any
of you guys play cyberpunk yet
it's also the 11 year anniversary of the
folgers
incest commercial folder commercial
yeah we watched it on the podcast incest
yeah
it's like the brother and sister and it
seems like really romantic or whatever
send me send me send me send me
something are you seeing what's going on
over on ian's feed
oh you meant to be back in five how
long's that been there
more than five probably um
i haven't played cyberpunk i'm waiting
until i get a ps5 because
i want to play it but it's so bad i know
that
it's pointless until i get the ps5 and
it's off the playstation store anyway
which is crazy
anything else maybe a bunch of people
still
donating saying i sent in my application
yeah we got i know we're getting them
i'm sorry it's just a lot it's like a
lot you guys
peace and love i think we made a mistake
because i think
the way we phrased it we made it seem
like we were yeah currently
that's what i tried yeah i tried to
explain that last week is that uh
i thought yeah i thought you did but i
am
warning you with peace and love any
applications
sent after today will be tossed in the
bin
actually whenever we get to the love
pieces
the simp off i have a little slideshow
so it might give people a better idea of
what went into me getting my job
okay so i think now is a good time to go
to the simp off before ready we skipped
our uh
year in review what are we i'll do it at
the end
okay we have so much to get to today
we've got the simp off in he's got his
gift giving
i mean it's ridiculous it's so much
happening
let's go ahead to the simp off this has
been a hotly
anticipated moment i think for the h3
podcast
uh with us today is love
who handles our highlights and our video
content he actually the reason that i
was introduced to him is because he has
a twitter account h3 out of context
that's right yep and love do you think
you are the biggest
h3 sim i'm definitely the biggest h3
uh sim and ethan simp wow
the knowledge is not the same as simp i
must say
i'm just going to put that out there if
i lose
i mean i won't but you know
we have excuses already but that's fine
now
now you say so
tell me what is your favorite thing
about me uh love
uh that you're completely uncensored
you say what you think and sometimes you
just
don't care about what people think about
you so you like that that's it
and have you ever like i know i've said
things that have got getting me canceled
and getting a lot of people
angry at me have you have i ever shaken
like your faith in me by something i've
said
no not really i i don't really have uh
opinion based on what like people say
just i just like the person
but i must say oh i'm gonna come i don't
like the politics and i think since i'm
from sweden
i'm sorry it doesn't connect with that
at all i'm out
yeah that would be cool but well
sometimes sometimes i guess
like yeah like when we goof on like
stuff like that that's good right the
dude is like
literally sweats motor oil so yeah yeah
of course that's a goof that's a good
thing okay
okay you know when trump does goofs i
don't care okay
it's funny okay now so here we have in
this corner is love simp number one
love all right we love we love love
now abe you guys you guys all know
and love uh a b the heartthrob president
heartthrob
which people in the chat are saying love
is also now a contestant
love is a contestant for a heartthrob
well this so do you understand what's
happening
if love comes in for the heartthrob and
the sim he leaves
a b with nothing total annihilation
he also put up lights in the background
he's trying to take it right yeah what
was that
i mean love really yeah that's the thing
with the lights are you
are you trying to take av out
[Laughter]
no i'm not looking to make any enemies
here it was not my idea to
like like make a actual symposium i just
stated
i might be a bigger simp than a b oh
abc what's happening here what do you
say
wait
merch
wait so love you can actually walk
around with that shirt on in sweden like
how
does that happen no i wouldn't wear that
outside anywhere
i wouldn't wear that anywhere
what are you rocking over there the hell
dan what the hell then
what baby was first i'm making sure that
i'm [ __ ] them kidding so
we revealed it first okay well so abe is
wearing the 200 shirt although
to be fair av i'm pretty sure that came
out while you were already with us right
no no no okay before i worked for you
the link wasn't working and i messaged
you on twitter and said hey the link's
not working
wow okay that's some points right there
now love are you walking out of frame to
to come over the top with something or
guess what uh oh uh-oh what is this
love pulled out a another one
love has two shabbat shalom shirts
love why do we have two shabbat shalom
shirts
i ordered the wrong size
oh my god that is pretty supportive i
gotta say that's a [ __ ]
oh zach a little shout out to zack oh
wow got some
very nice okay so a b
a b obviously you guys all know um
he's a fan and that's how we met
super fan what you could say you would
consider yourself a super fan right abby
i don't i don't necessarily think i
would i mean like i'm a huge fan i feel
like super fan is someone who knows
like everything about every episode and
i haven't watched every single episode
or every video
what's your favorite thing about me baby
favorite thing about you um i like that
you're very sincere
i [ __ ] cheated on the narcissism test
ethan
go on don't
attracted me to you guys was you and ila
remind me a lot of uh me and my wife so
i see a lot of similarities that i don't
know i feel like me and lena were always
looking at things like from the outside
and i and one of the first videos i've
seen with you guys
i think you said something similar like
you and hila nothing was ever normal
with you guys so
all right i feel like you're in the
outside looking again well maybe
you're down i feel like you're
downplaying your fandom so
he literally said he wanted to meet like
robert de niro and you
yeah i don't think he doesn't matter no
like yeah i just feel like super fans
like someone that knows everything i
just i feel like that's taking away
you don't like the title i think let me
ask you this
let me ask you this if you had to make a
wish on you you were
you were dying and you had to make one
make a wish to meet a celebrity who
would you choose before you knew me
before i knew you yeah
well alpha channel is getting kind of
old you wouldn't hit out
why would you choose al pacino what's he
going to stadium
you know what i mean it's like hey al
pacino what the [ __ ] he going to do
great ass all right let's get on with
the contest all right
okay okay so we put together um wait we
have a theme song are you ready
[Music]
all right that's okay
so we put together 25 questions
for each of you guys to answer of course
i actually don't know all these so i'll
be interested to know if i know some of
these you know
so let's get started um dan would you
like to administer the to the uh
examination or maybe yeah i could
who put this to queller me and ian why
don't you
contribute as well ian
you're hosting damn it go ahead
me i'm doing it yes you number two
eating two on this
narcissism scale you're hosting okay
uh question one ethan asks you to order
him a pizza
who do you call and what do you get
[Music]
good question can i just answer let's go
with the love
first let me say the person who you call
is a tough choice
so let's just narrow it down to the
toppings what would you get the toppings
because papa's obviously falling out of
grace so topping wise what would you put
on it
um it's well
anyone answer or just we're going one at
a time
we gotta get just a cheese pizza with
black olives
okay that's decent a b you got anything
else uh
black olives jalapeno and uh
[Music]
i remember what you ordered on the front
of this episode there's one more
i think you both win honestly i'll give
you both okay point for
point four i mean a b word is closer a
black olive is the one
is the right answer to be honest like
black olive is the one that
that i would put on every pie you know i
kind of want to give the point to love
because he wasn't in the stu
i'm not going to though you guys both
but i'm impressed love all right next
question
okay what is the topic of the very first
h3 video i'll start with a b
uh you know what hold on hold on one
person answer we gotta alternate or
something because they're giving each
other the answers
[Music]
you know what i mean or they gotta think
maybe this game shows not is the format
is funky here
the person who knows it should just
shout it out if you know the answer just
goes yeah
it's a game of speed yeah and if you
answer wrong you lose a point
zach you keep score guys
we did not think this through okay so
right now it's one one it's one one
okay ask the question again ian okay
what is the topic of the very first h3
video chocolate
that is correct good work abe
maybe he said chocolate yeah that's
right he's right i thought it was about
wiping
right see you're rocky president
go ahead next question let's go illa had
a project in college
right okay well done you know were you
really h3
yet though yes yes though we were we
were at the title
before youtube actually when we were
working
we literally posted that video to h3
productions the youtube channel
yeah it was our very first video but we
came up with that name
even before youtube when we were just
working on a kids
children's book really yeah i forgot
that
next question let's go in okay
ethan asks you to record one reality
television
show for him to watch after the podcast
what show right
bachelor what'd you say ab that's right
i'm gonna give you both the point for
that one they both said yeah they both
said the bachelor and the bachelorette
not 90 day fiance no that should i don't
like that show anymore
what it sucks it's boring and repetitive
and sad
we can't it's too sad like they started
bringing kids into the mix
it's crazy but there's actually new
episodes and we're
not even watching them wow i'm like well
i like bachelor nation all the way back
it went downhill after big ad huh yeah
it did that's the peak
it got too sad go ahead let's splash
through this let's go
ethan says he was up until 4 a.m working
on his class to get a high rank in some
video game
what game is he referring to world of
warcraft
oh geez one answer
it's got to be csgo right no it's diablo
oh my god yeah of course yeah
yeah i also did counter-strike i don't
know the way it was
the guy himself was working everybody
was wrong
world of warcraft all right no points no
points three two
a b leads three go ahead okay out of the
following four video titles which one is
not from the h3h3 channel lime exe
curling exe laser exe
or flexing exe by mixi
love say again he said lime extra mine
is not baby
video and flesh you're incorrect
oh if you got it again it's flex
[Music]
all right let's just smell this [ __ ]
just keep slamming it yeah
being embarrassed
you know don't be embarrassed be proud
man own it
you're a superman this one's a little
more open-ended so
we'll let each person and then ethan you
can i mean it's pretty basic but
ethan's gerd is acting up and he won't
stop screeching
like a pterodactyl in heat but he asks
you to get him a big cup of coffee right
before
show anyway ela says don't do it
what do you do let's start with a b
gila has veto power
okay so you listen to it
um honestly i'd give him the coffee
the the gerd has become a big part of
the show and
very often it's memeable
and you know i don't think it's very
interesting i know what the real answer
is
i appreciate the perspectives but av is
correct
abs right but love i appreciate the
support
i really do but i know that that's the
right answer
you always do you don't cross the line
i don't want it this is funny there was
actually yeah that's really funny it was
really good
this would kind of carry over to the
next question then which is um
ethan is in a twitter beef with some
random influencer
eli says he should not respond do you
a advise him to let it go or b
prepare for war and compile counter
intelligence to destroy them
let's start with love this time again
i'd prepare for war love goes to war
when i first met ethan i was so afraid
ila hated me because of this because
i was like i feel like i kept
encouraging him to getting to
uh boris um
so your answer is also go to war yeah
you guys are both correct
it's definitely going to warp time the
thing is
you prepare for battle it's like
learning karate it's like you know
you hope you don't have to use it but
you got to be ready if you do
so you both did great there
definitely got that one right
okay so uh moving on
which of the following h3 podcast
highlights
has the most dislikes
is it a how bad is the sonic movie
oh b ethan klein discusses the
playstation 5.
b joker hysteria is out of control
or d h3 guarantees that bernie sanders
will win the president
i actually don't know but if i had to
guess well you go ahead a b go ahead and
uh what's your guess i'm gonna ask are
these all actual titles there's no
no no no that's all these are all top
dislike thailand yeah
uh e i think it's the sonic one
i actually said b which is uh which is
the playstation one right i think it's
the sonic one but
i said i'm sorry i said d oh so they're
both saying b all right so what's the
answer again
the answer is joker hysteria is out of
control
really oh with almost 6 000 dislikes
why was everyone angry about that
wait so that must have been an old one
because i remember we did a
joker highlight not too long ago okay
two weeks ago
yeah i think this was right when the uh
when the joker movie came out
the recent joke yeah i remember i
remember going over
i didn't know that the top disliked
highlights and
and then that one jumped out i don't
know why people were so angry you want
to read some of the comments
uh ian uh i'll pull it up
my favorite movie of all time i love
that
in the meantime i can ask another
question yeah why don't you look up some
some well go ahead and go ahead and yeah
okay
uh here's another open-ended question
you get a text from ethan at 2 am it
says
i need you to hide a body what do you
do next let's start with a b
this time i do it i owe the man my life
so well give us a okay you ha what's
your method what's your first
you need a game plan so it's not just a
brief game
so so so wait yes is the only answer or
is it
what's the question exactly
yeah this is serious [ __ ] dude hey b
what do you do
as they make a phone call make an
open-ended phone call leave your leave
your phone on leave it upstairs
be there in 10 minutes let the guard
know man
i'm just playing i'm just i'm making a
change jesus
[Laughter]
love what do you think well of course i
do it but how
well i'll take the body and i would
plant it at
the current ceo of pizza or
papa john's papa john holy [ __ ] bro no
so we can get back to papa in the house
you know oh
two birds with one stone two papas and
ones
the real answer is to say no
because that's illegal and we don't
condone we
as someone who cares very much about
both you i would not want you to to uh
risk yourselves to help me who is
clearly
acting was clearly acting
out of character as it would not murder
anybody
i've got a couple joker uh comments here
from that okay
um the top one ethan's saying
i think it's just meh ethan reviewing a
movie he has not
watched did i review it before i watched
it
because i liked it i think you did
uh imagine confidently reviewing and
reading a movie you haven't seen jesus
christ well i did like the movie for the
record
here's what 2 000 up votes major douche
points for bagging on a movie you've
never seen before good job
i don't remember what i said what did i
say
i think we just we i was talking about
the trailer i guess i was responding to
i was responding to everybody losing
their mind about it but i think what i
said was
that all i don't like superhero movies
ah whatever i like the movie
sorry everybody
[Laughter]
all right let's do just a couple more
okay
[Music]
uh okay this is a quick one so just
shout out to answer
who was the first guest on the podcast
pewdiepie
correct
[Music]
no not correct it was right but it's
it's on the h3 channel though right
what's your answer love and then we'll
we'll say oh
yeah you're not right it has to be on
twitch
uh or is it timer
i don't know his name but he could be
checking the chat time is
yeah the first uh episode posted was
with uh justin
right all right justin pewdiepie was
number two i believe
that's right was the first episode you
ever recorded or am i misremembering
i don't think it was with bert but why
didn't we actually record pewdiepie
first
we did record pewdiepie oh [ __ ] and we
posted
justin first yeah oh we got a little
abby road let it be situation going on
here
i think a b is actually correct wow i'm
just
i don't cut him [ __ ] i mean he
couldn't have known that
yeah i don't think so i don't think he's
fake news episode
episode four you guys talking about how
long the edit took on the pewdiepie one
i'm totally kidding go ahead yeah
what's the difference back uh six to
three
ab leads let's let's do three more to
give love a chance to climb back
all right all right three more just
shout it out
uh what is ethan's favorite anime
um that's correct correct
love good job okay point for love
job dude uh what was the name of the
parody facebook page that ethan made
that got shut down
very good question tick
[Music]
i'll give you guys a clue it was in
response to
soflo antonio oh
[ __ ] i don't remember the name though i
know what you're talking about we're
just reading
there's mother something uh a mother's
against
facebook mothers against dabbing
facebook mothers against debbie and
that was not different it was so flow
bro
bro that whole saga is when i got into
h3 really
yeah i think a lot of people got tuned
in yeah the whole sofa thing is when i
started watching
good times man so let's keep going
uh okay okay he's he's climbing back now
okay uh who were we watching when the h3
podcast stream
was taken down and given a strike
[Music]
no one no one knows nobody [ __ ] easy
one easy
no reading chat i know i see i see it
see
you guys okay the chat's on a delay but
he's a
media personality
[Music]
conspiracy he has a very
uh hoarse voice
[Music]
his name is alex jones his name is alex
all right you guys let's do let's do one
more
just for all of the marbles the next
last one all right one more last last
question last question
uh what happened to the fupa fund
oh god ian what the [ __ ]
this is actually my question zach why
would you like to do a twitter account
with
the video game lawyer to help other
creators to
fight lawsuits yeah it's kind of a trick
question it's the thing that keemstar
always says
zach you're such a dick
maybe you want to give the the answer
that is good i spent it on my [ __ ]
lawsuit
it's expensive lawsuit some of it went
why am i having to relitigate this
some of it went down people the lawsuit
was more expensive than we thought we've
been over this a thousand [ __ ] times
why
what happened to the poop
you stole the true fan would know this
you're right right you're right
true that's a really important thing
true
all right i guess that concludes the
simp off well thank you guys love i have
to say
you did pretty good you did pretty good
i'm not going to hate on you but i think
ab
shined through and uh he's defended his
title
s-i-m-p as the ultimate s-i-m-p so
when we when we watch the slideshow
you'll feel better
thank you guys thank you
that was rough man i i have to say i was
a little disappointed
i thought these guys are going to know
me better than myself because you know
sometimes you bring out like ariana
grande has these super fans that are
like
grande heads or whatever and they're
like ow
she wore a pink dress on may 13th
tuesday and
she's like oh i didn't even know that
that didn't happen
you know what i mean these guys didn't
know [ __ ] about me
i knew a decent amount let's go over the
slideshow you'll see you'll see what's
like
oh we don't need to go over the slides
you got your crown a b what slideshow
he put together like above a 15 page
slideshow about
what a big shape he is okay
well he made it in case he lost to to
re-litigate the argument
no it was also to show people who keep
bombarding about an application
all right get it i have a slight
transport just rest on your
just just rest on your laurels
what else is left we've got well we have
the gift
yeah so today we come together on this
christmas
to celebrate um santa himself
santa vs the grinch ian
tell us about what you planned here
today for us
all right well uh
everybody i'd like to welcome you all
to the very first um
h3 podcast craigsmiss
now i i i like you guys i like you guys
but i don't i don't know how
if i like you guys enough to spend like
a lot of money
sure i decided to do it all just
exclusively on craigslist with basically
no budget
at all great and that's the budget i
gave you so
yes yes it balances out um
but first i you guys got a couple gifts
for everybody that's been
dispersed amongst the crew so if anybody
wants to open any of those we could
start with dan
so sure so me and eva went all out on
gifts this year
and we wanted to make it a really it's
been a long year really hard year so we
wanted to make it special for everybody
all right so should i open mine go ahead
down okay all right let me switch to
myself here
all right so this is the 2020 h3 gift
contest what do we got
it's a vin diesel 2021
every page is full of vin diesel
there's actually another one here hold
on van book the vin book right
guys really look how beautiful she is
wow
it's big mama
what the [ __ ] is this show it up to the
camera damn
big mama undo it's a huge pair of
underwear that's awesome
wow that's so kind that's probably like
size
20 xl for you put it up to
well thank you uh you're very welcome
dan wow who else
who else has one you're very very
welcome uh
i have gifts as well open them up go
ahead everybody start opening everybody
just
tear them open all right i'm just gonna
say this is leaving neverland
[Music]
oh my god i wish i thought of that
oh the last airbender the last airbender
the movie by
the m 3.0
on imdb i don't know if you've seen that
but it's really bad
did you probably did you like it baby no
i didn't watch it no yeah
good well merry christmas thank you god
bless
god bless you oh should i open this one
too just tear them open guys
i got a stud undies
the green screen is kind of messing it
up but as you can see
there's extra space for
all the way down to the floor
[Music]
last time i came to california i was a
kid my aunt had one of these i always
wanted one i never bought one so you go
that gets kind of weird because it's
actually just kind of cool it's like
it's a throwback it's definitely a
throwback yeah
what else anything else i got something
it's uh
some flag yep
hold it up you might have to click your
green screen
yeah yeah yeah let me turn it off this
flag is something i'm very proud
to have bought for you zack very excited
to show it to the world
[Music]
it's a flag of o.j simpson on
the freeway hold it up for the camera
the dude is [ __ ] sick
don't you have a camera it says the
juice is loose and it's an image of oj
running from the police bro this is so
[ __ ] safe
merry christmas that is so [ __ ] cool
so i'm sure you'll that'll be the
perfect uh deck i absolutely love it
thank you
yeah you're welcome is that everything
i have a few more oh it's actually
hooked up
oh yeah wait are we opening ian's as
well no no no no no these i think
that just got hooked up because there
were funny things oh okay
go ahead i've got a urinal shot glass
show it come on
show it it kind of yeah show the dang
thing oh that's gross
what are you talking about hold on
i'm gonna open it okay it's a shot glass
that looks like a urinal
[ __ ] sick that is kind of sick yeah i
mean
it's disgusting
[Laughter]
and it kind of goes i [ __ ] love it
with the next one
oh he's got another one yeah i i guess
we should have
we should have been more prank gift box
plant urinal so this one this is because
of your pooping in public story
[Laughter]
oh you can piss some plants yeah so it's
like a urinal you plug into the plant
and then you pee in it
wow i love it i'm going to use this
every day thank you
did you film your parents reaction to
that absolute [ __ ] loot
thank you very much thank you guys this
is amazing exactly now you don't have to
store your urine in a chest
[Laughter]
i got i can do it in the planters and i
can do it in a shot glass
congratulations merry christmas thank
you thank you this is some real grinch
grinch gifts yeah a little bit i [ __ ]
love that oj flag
it's some cool [ __ ] [ __ ]
we spent a long time on amazon just
looking for the weirdest and worst gifts
possible
that's everything right is that all that
i think that's it let's get through your
stuff yeah let's get to the real
sh the real show here well let's uh
let's start with
with you guys since everyone else just
opened some sure
i got it oh so ian got each of us
a personalized gift they're
they're quite big oh my god
so you got this for free on craig on
craigslist
it's all free or around zero to ten
dollars
okay here i'm opening it it's wrapped
really nicely
look at this it's very substantial
[Music]
only the best were these sanitized and
stuff
yes it was wiped down most for the most
part
holy [ __ ] how much did you pay for that
i think that was like eight dollars what
two no
way this is crazy we've actually got
this
like gift on craigslist oh my god
it's a papa john's what wow
that's amazing and it has magnets like i
could probably just put this on the top
of my car
yeah you should be able to because oh my
god this is amazing
wow he last two because the first one's
a little small
what i love it here
yeah you have to cruise around you could
pop that on the gatsby maybe
go for a ride what's going on here
because it's a box of like
it's the wrong box that's not the actual
item yeah i figured
okay so it's in a it's wrapped in
red gift wrapping no ela is very stylish
and
fashionable so i thought maybe she'd
like this shirt
it's a shirt that says what does it say
hentai and how much was this one it kind
of smells like
i i think that was around four dollars
it smells like
craigslist i hate to say i think you
overpaid for that
it's authentic i can't afford to go get
the laundry detergent
you can't deliver us [ __ ] unwashed
craigslist laundry bruh you know i'm
really curious how everything
smells because i can't smell any of it
oh it smells awful
i can't smell anything it all smells
great to me
this next one might be a little stinky
just just a heads up
ela's opening the mat it's like a jared
little
gift taped together pretty well she's
been
good dana's approaching with his knife
as always
no need dan thank you oh my god
so there appears to be a young
a mannequin of some sort a black
mannequin it's a black baby
oh my god a
read what the overall song i'm a cosby
kid
oh no oh my god
is this a this thing looks so dirty and
it's hair it's authentic it's like it's
so actually
so put it back it's cursed this thing is
so cursed bro
this is the type of it should smell can
i get a smell update
how much did you pay for this again i
believe that one was around
four okay okay who wants four dollars
that bad
i drove a ways to pick that up i drove
along
what what who's that in the sleigh who
is that we feel the gas tank on the
sleigh to go get that
who was selling it's kind of like really
well made like the outfit is pretty sick
yeah i think the shoes say uh hey hey
hey it does it says hey hey
tell me about who what did they look
like who you bought this from
uh they kind of had a they wouldn't stop
squinting and they were kind of like it
kind of
seemed like why do you want this oh they
ask you that
well they were they were like have a
good time
oh my god
[Music]
yeah so so is this like a dummy that
you're supposed to put your hand into
kind of thing or
no oh man this is the type of thing that
you burn and then it shows back up in
your room
uh how about let's uh let's do uh a b
maybe you want to pop those open yeah
get open the makeup guy i just picked
around the corner again
go for the larger yeah the large one is
the
oh how do i how do i open
give me a second while you do that maybe
zach can open his yes
uh very nice box which i sanitized
thoroughly this morning
of course yeah but did you sanitize
what's in the box
you're gonna trip there might be a
little gift on the outside from covet
claws himself
so wash your hands
dude you sealed this the [ __ ] like what
the [ __ ]
right now we have some unwrapping going
on
okay is this what i think it is i hope i
hope you like it i hope it's
is this a joker trench coat aaron leto
authentic hot topic exclusive actually
whoa and how much was that this was i
think
10. big money this was the top of my
budget
joker i remember seeing that at hot
topic it actually smells like it was
originally eighty dollars
eighty dollars yeah try it on
i was thinking zach made a promise to us
about he was going to do if he was
proven to be the psycho that is true he
promised
what was the promise i actually didn't
remember he was going to do joker face
with mayo
oh so i think he might have to pop this
jacket on and fulfill
that he has made well let's see if it
fits try it on zach
don't be shy hold on
zack what's the holdup he's working on
okay oh it was frozen i think they're
staring at me i think it was frozen
does it fit
hey pretty good fit
so maybe while a b is opening his we can
get uh
we can get some helmets for zach yes
[Music]
with you i actually do yes let's see
what kind of mayonnaise do you have
[Music]
almonds
[Laughter]
you want to get to work over there we'll
check back in with you
i'm going to wash my hands real quick
before the mail
before the mail and then i'll uh i'll
start the
big strategy now for
before you pop this open or as you're
opening it
i know you're a big fan of mj um i know
exactly what this is
and i wanted to get you something to
commemorate the fandom but unfortunately
this is
all i could find so go ahead and
pop that open
abs opening what looks like to be a
picture frame
flat and square he's tearing it eagerly
apart
uh so far he's not reacting jackson
five victory tour that's awesome now the
now that show the frame to to everybody
it's the newspaper announcing that he's
dead oh my god
what how did you find that
you found that on craigslist yes
why would anyone fit that and then why
would they give it oh
like what did you buy that or was it
free
it was five dollars and it was framed
read go ahead read the headline a b king
of pop is dead at 50.
man maybe you could put that i wonder if
like
on your wall i wonder if when people
bought this
again maybe are you gonna hang that
you better hang that
oh my god you better hang out you know
what's funny ian
yeah my mom has this book this victory
to her book of course she does
maybe you could pop open the other gif
real quick too
what's the next one a [ __ ] semen
sample of michael jackson
it's it's in a similar vein so you know
it's a bundle
so a b is unwrapping yet another slender
kind of frame looking gift
yeah this is the thickest wall connor
it's wrapped in cardboard
only the best from craig claus
craig amy is ravenously
tearing away he's pulled out a book of
some sort
what is it a.b it's moonwalk by michael
uh
it's a biography i believe jackson
how many copies do you own already i
don't but i remember
i remember a line i read the library
once now there should be one
is there something else in there too in
that package
there's something it's the underwear
with the blood stain
it's a backup paper announcing that he
is also
dead how do you get all these papers
why are there so many papers floating
around about him dying
oh just in case you misplaced the other
one i wanted you to have
some sort of backup how much did you pay
for that one
this entire bundle was five dollars wow
so you got the whole michael jackson
death kit
bundle for five dollars yes can you read
the headline on that one
music loses can we take a
moment to acknowledge his icon oh yeah
how farrah fawcett died on the worst day
possible because every newspaper looked
like this with michael
and then farah foss that was just in the
corner of every newspaper that day sarah
fawcett died on the same day
and why do you even know also and also
the guy from the tonight show
wow yeah well don't die in the same day
as me [ __ ]
oh well thank you again yeah that was
very good i gotta say i'm impressed
amazing so you're gonna frame both of
those you should
maybe i want your whole all your halls
all your wallets just be covered with
michael jackson death announcements and
then bring someone over and just
film their faces it dawns on them your
entire house is just
michael jackson's death announcements
i'm gonna i'm gonna
do half ethan half michael jackson
everywhere
death announcement i'm still alive
[ __ ] now you're coming
now i got something for dan this is the
this is the one
free item and i i
deeply apologize dan for this really
is that yeah it's i gotta put alfredo
down okay and i don't know how you're
gonna show it because it's pretty large
it's pretty light yeah it is extremely
large so if i can just
okay so it's basically the size of dan's
whole body
i mean it's a normal looks like it's
falling apart just grabbing
so yes it it will fall apart it's the
structure
of the item i would describe it as the
size of a small
donkey you might need some help
disposing of it after
so oh it doesn't sound like much of a
gift that we're disposing
immediately this was the bottom tier
craig
craigsmiths though dan is ripping open
what can only be described as a
mass massive
weirdly shaped [ __ ] smell
dan reported that there's a stink coming
up
just the way i like it reports of a
stinky cradle
what the [ __ ] is that this was described
to me
as a haunted baby cradle
i can't bring that into my [ __ ] house
that survived a fire
in 1930 and it was free
do you know why it was free in your
mouth
the the seller described it as unsolved
oh my god can you see that
you should bring it here bro you really
shouldn't have brought that into my
house
the [ __ ] out of you guys today he double
parked he brought you up
you really brought this into my [ __ ]
house at least you gave it to dan and
not me
i figured
she's trying to get pregnant she's
trying to get pregnant bro let's get
that haunted [ __ ] off
be let's see there's another present in
the present okay
in case dan doesn't like it i gave him
one more little gift tucked inside
bro hold on hold on hold on why would he
not like what is with this haunted
brim wait what happened dan nobody saw
that
oh nobody saw the brim okay
so don't re don't rest on the other side
because she'll never get pregnant again
you know why it was freeze because it's
the curse and you can only give it away
you can't sell it that's how you
you remove the well now it is dan dan
has to give it away
you gotta give it away on craigslist now
dan yeah
you have no choice okay what the [ __ ]
man that's creepy yeah
um merry christmas yeah
and what was the person like you picked
that up from yeah
she was actually very kind and sweet but
she said
it's been her grandmother's and then it
was her mom's
and now hers and she said she just had
to get it out
and and and what about the curse though
it seems like it's been in perfect
let's focus on the curse well i mean she
probably
oh my god they're saying put the doll in
put the doll in there
fill the prophecy she's probably just
been freed from like an
80-year uh thing that's been put on her
family i think we can
i think we can crush the curse if we put
the little black baby doll in it
can you can you get the cake
you gotta show that
oh no you gotta see this
get the [ __ ] away it's so cursed
we have to light that on fire man oh my
god it
it fits in there wait weirdly like
like shoot out it yeah yeah this is
really cursed
okay so this brim alfredo get away
so the story is it was in her family for
three generations and she just needed to
get rid of it
yeah i think you'd been terrorizing her
bro is
oh you're welcome dan thank you and
there there is one last gift that was
inside the cradle is this related
yeah a little consolation prize it's not
related but something a little more
okay lighthearted all right
and by light-hearted i mean a child's
heart
it's just a baby dude that's the most
cursed [ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
it is oh [ __ ] yeah it's actually awesome
dude
show it off what is that rudy giuliani
bobblehead
can we put him in the brim too please no
i don't want this anywhere near that i
like this i'm keeping this
how much was that that seems like a
collector item
uh that was i think around 10
actually good deal all right all right
i'll definitely take that for the
uh in exchange for getting the cursed
cradle thank you she actually asked for
20
and i said rudy's lost his mind and you
have two if you think i'm giving you 20
bucks
you negotiated that huh and she said
okay you drive a hard bargain
i love that you negotiated on these
phrases we got to take a photo of the
baby in that brand for our social media
because like that's kind of that should
be our new logo i think
so that concludes craig's miss and wow
i guess maybe we can that was the best
craigslist ever yeah
maybe we can wrap it all up with a
little mayo on zach's face
yeah the papa john thing is honestly
sick
we have to put that in our new this is
so cool
we have to put that in our new uh studio
for sure
it's legit and also there's a spot for
the light so we can light it up with
like
purple light or something cool maybe
i'll put you in charge of that maybe
yeah god bless
great job ian this is why this is why
this is why ian's the best more the man
segments
thank you did not i got to tell you i
don't like that cursed [ __ ]
do not like the curse the vlogs are
playing with my feet
as we come to the uh end of our
year and our last episode of the year
we'll be back in january beginning of
january
i want to play a super cut
of our year to date to show some of our
greatest moments here
um so let's let's do a little year in
review here best of 20 20.
take a look hey would you like to uh
play
play us uh music wait we've been in this
[ __ ] basement for a year
well this almost no the beginning of the
year we weren't in the basement
i think everything got worse around
march or april yeah when
quarantine started to make some [ __ ] up
i thought maybe uh
doing something for like h3 might be fun
oh i love it make a little something for
h3 i don't know maybe it'll suck but
we should give it a shot i'd love to
hear that
you once asked me
who my dream get would be
on hot ones do you remember who
what i said who'd you say i don't
remember papa john
i've always thought this would be a lot
of fun that was right
what a year there it's gonna be a great
time it's gonna be a pizza journey
edges are not clean we're in the
ballpark of an
eight um you're a top you are a tough
pizza critic my friend
i was challenged by someone to get
blocked
by o.j simpson and i frankly didn't
think it was possible
but here we go i was blocked
so big ed is dumping this mayonnaise on
the spatula oh my god
it's so cold what it's cold it's a good
moment
and the second thing you're going to
notice is it smells like egg salad
sandwiches
now zach go ahead and tell me from your
experience how is this going
you know it's not that bad how's this
going for you
terrible
coming out i would love to see leafy
come back and try to exist in the
landscape today
today for the loss of a great one
leafy
which means you've lost a significant
amount of weight and darn you look good
wait slow it down say that part again
the jamaican part
you can't you can't go any slower love
is very important to me and ela
and uh our community and um
we thought trisha paytas now that's the
next season of the bachelorette
oh god that has to be theodore i got him
his first razor scooter wow
that's super nice was there anything for
ethan
i personally think that this is a huge
problem called it
i think this is january i think that uh
i wish that people were taking it more
seriously that's just yeah conspiracy
theory
this is alex jones and you are watching
infowars
look at this it's a [ __ ] sword
it's the next weird starting kit dude
[Applause]
it's cool to be a sip y'all don't ever
say otherwise
because i sing for ela i love the snips
so abs joining us um are you age three
i i am i'm obviously number one this
morning i learned that i'm a foot fetish
icon voted the best feat on youtube bro
do you
even do your research like i mean this
is just embarrassing for you bro
6.4 dude you are out of your element bro
how dare you come and make that
let's say let's say hello to a i n
oh wow hey whoa
a i
thank you for joining us how are you
today i'm really good thank you
have you visited blocked
we take a look at a channel known as the
prince family
the creator known as jay station serial
offender
james charles of the aced family this is
the people
versus the quartering this peed in my
basement
he's literally just sitting amongst
urine
it smells like urine
guilty they said it would never happen
me and trisha making a podcast and uh
frankly i thought they were right
i wonder how many episodes we we make
before before this whole thing is
burning
wow what a year
wow
some deep cuts dude i liked it that's
amazing that was really good
nice job guys that was really fun to
watch and it really does make me
we've been through a lot this year a lot
of good stuff man what a year
well i hope that our next year can be
you know next year i'm excited because
we're moving into our new studio
which is super [ __ ] it's gonna be
super epic
i mean it's going to be like a legit
production studio i just can't wait to
see what it's going to be like because
we got
the two companies next to each other so
we're all going to get to it's just
it's going to be a lot of creativity in
one place yeah definitely
yeah it's going to be awesome i'm just
so looking forward to being in our new
studio
for the pandemic to be over so we can
bring people in
um we're going to have lots of space to
[ __ ]
just crash the gatsby into [ __ ] and just
i don't know just it's going to be funny
we haven't even
gotten to see the gatsby in like nine
months now no
i miss it yeah a b felt the power of it
yeah very lightly so zach
as we close off this year as we sign off
as our last episode of 2020
uh the joker brain himself
top narcissist on the street podcast
uh as you wear the joker outfit would
you like to play us off
as you apply mayonnaise to your face
zach
here sure should you play his video what
video
he's made a he made a finale video
with a song and everything where at the
bottom of the doc
sure i'd love to play that exactly
2020 video yeah so let me play zach
prepare the 2020 video
and then we can cut what i got age
restricted
it's unlisted how'd your video get you
just addicted zach
i don't know what oh because you wrote
[ __ ] the title
oh no okay that'll do with that we'll do
it so let's do
zack's music and let's run us off with
the joker face so
[ __ ] 2020 and happy 2021 everybody we'll
see you in 2021 we love you all thanks
for coming on this crazy journey with us
and here's to another great year ahead
h3 podcast forever we're not going
anywhere
foot soldier army [ __ ] yeah let's go
i'm so wonderful this was gonna be the
one excitement from
days we were having fun
then all of a sudden in another land
people were getting sick
we were scared he's already
[Music]
that's not gonna come off easy
it's our big finale
lather that [ __ ] on boy come on don't be
shy
like it's not sunscreen
[Music]
don't be shy come on zach this is it we
want to thank this is a big finale
[Music]
[Music]
there it is
i love my job
[Music]
come on baby the vaccine's here we're
right here
that's a joker brain right there if i've
ever seen one
like under your eyes yeah
[Music]
bravo to everybody to the whole cast and
crew
to joker brain zach for a great 2020
and guys we love you have a happy and
fantastic new year
and we'll see you in 2021
so this was awesome we'll be back in
january
beginning of january thank you guys
thank you zach for the song yeah yeah
that was awesome dude that was a [ __ ]
challenge
it was emotional play us out i know all
right
place that with that song here we go
thanks for watching everybody we'll see
you next year thanks for watching
people were getting sick we didn't know
we were scared 2020
sean evans and jake paul scams
[Music]
is
[Music]
now we're living in fear